can you talk about uh like uh we had T
pay on the podcast and he said most
rappers don't wear their nice jewelry
out they wear the fake stuff out but
then they wait to what did he say about
like they'll do when they do shows the
fake stuff shines better in the lights I
never I've never worn a piece of fake
jurry really n cuz we wanted to do a rap
song with Steve where he's just laced
out and only fake [__] yeah I've never
I've never uh I've never worn fake
jewelry authenticity is key for me yeah
you know what I mean no matter what it
was it just has to be authentic even
before I could afford jewelry if you
pull up my second album trap music I I
had like a a little Bob Marley rope it
was just like a little a little rope
with a picture of Bob Marley on it I
couldn't afford jewelry at the time you
see what I'm saying so rather than wear
some fake jewelry I wore something that
was authentic and a true representation
of you know the culture that I that I
represent
right on man and so that's your second
album yeah that's my second album just
turned 20 years old this year and now
you're you got your second to last album
is that right yeah I'm working on it
yeah um I got two more albums and then
I'm out of here you're calling it quits
retiring yeah I'm done whoa yeah the the
name of this second to last album is
kiss the king it is and then the last
album's called kill the the king M this
is true yeah dude so uh and you and you
have songs already for this are you
still in the studio making songs
definitely have songs but definitely
still in the studio making songs you
pick and choose you're like no no no I
want this one I want that one do that
one for this one I want this go to
number four this is going to be number
five well it doesn't exactly work like
that okay so the second to last album
has a Vibe there's a vibe there um and
their Vibe
is uh how can I say
so that Vibe is is is a
worldly um sort of
uh communication with girls you know
communication to girls and women and you
know for I guess for like a player you
know what I'm saying
R&B you know kind of old
school Soulful right and kill the king
is much more dramatic sort of like a
action movie okay you feel me I like uh
yeah so what what kind of a timeline do
you see see these albums coming out on
um I might be able to I might be able to
produce them both uh within within the
year wow and are you going to hold on to
them because you're like okay once I do
this I'm done or are you like eager to
put them out I'm eager to put them out
man I'm eager to I'm ready to you know
I'm ready to I feel
like I've already kind of evolved Beyond
just just music yeah um of course but
but in order to walk away I have to earn
the right okay to walk away that means I
have to put an exclamation point on this
this this this discography this this
body of work that that I've dedicated my
life to uh you don't just like leave it
and just walk away and never come back
never you know what I mean you are you
going to tour I'm sure yeah I'm sure I
will so it sounds like you're pretty
well thought out do you have like the
next a 5year plan a 10e plan a legacy
plan you seem like kind of mus just your
life because you already have that
mapped out pretty far in advance it
seems like you're very calculated are
you like sitting there like you know
visualizing your life yes but that
vision changes yeah that vision changes
as as my experiences grow you know what
I mean uh like I just put out my first
film as a director uh a couple months
ago departments yeah and so you know
with uh the success of this is now kind
of
prioritized um writing producing and
directing films you know that's cool uh
so I I I will be working on on my next
film as a director at the top of the
year next year is directing as stressful
as like making an
album you think or is it like uh is it
just fun it's different can be it can be
as stressful it depends on who you're
collab ating with yeah if you surround
yourself with people who take it as
seriously as you then you know
everybody's just committed to the task
at hand yeah dedicated to getting it
done you know if you surround yourself
with people who you know are not as is
not as focused and committed it could be
a little more stressful do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude